- Before we say goodbye,
we'd like to play a quick
round of Drewth or Dare.
You get to ask me anything
or dare me to do anything.
And I go there.
So Chloe, here you are.
How are you today?
- I'm great, how are you?
- You look lovely.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome, Drewth or dare?
- Dare
- Do it.
What, what, what do I do?
- So I've had a really old
voicemail for my whole life
and I dare you to record
my voicemail for me.
- I would be honored to.
Okay, give me your phone.
- [Chloe] Okay.
- Okay, okay.
Hi, this is Drew Barrymore.
I'm recording the outgoing
message for Chloe's inbox.
Please leave a message
but also remember to have a wonderful day.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
I felt a lot pressure.
I really wanted to get it right.
Oh gosh, thank you Chloe.
Thank you for letting me
a part of your voicemail.
(upbeat music)